for
when thinking about the prophet Sall alam's identity as a servant Prophet as a servant messenger
we want to think and consider what is the most identifiable governing Spirit
of that identity of being a servant prophet
and we find that in s Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam Mercy when he talks about himself
he talks about himself as being Mercy
as being compassion sallallahu alaihi wasallam and when Allah tells us
and he tells the prophet wasallam essentially about his governing reality on this life he
says
we have not sent you
but as
mercy
and as compassion for all of
creation here means everything of other than Allah
and so the mercy of the messenger Muhammad sallallah alaihi
wasallam is that fundamental identifier of what it means to be a servant
so that means that for you and I if I think about my identity as a
servant
I have to hear Allah telling me
y
Muhammad
fatim
I have sent you
to the world around you
as mercy and compassion and the prophet wasam was told by Allah
and it is because of the mercy
that Allah has bestowed upon you
you are gentle and kind to
them
if you were harsh
and hard-hearted they would have fled from you
how often brothers and sisters do we experience a harshness in our lives
harshness with our families harshness with our loved ones harshness at work at school it's coming
from a lack of Spirited
mercifulness that Allah subhana T wants to be at the essence of our servanthood Allah subh
tells us about the
prophet
that verily in the messenger Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam you have this messenger that has come
to you from
yourselves that it's very heavy for him
to see you and I and Humanity go through hardship it's hard for him Sall alai
wasallam he's very worried and concerned about us and with the believing men and women
gentle and
compassionate so you see that the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam his Spirit of servanthood
meant that he was deeply
caring
his mercifulness meant
that his compassion exuded all the time for all when thinking about his duty as a
messenger of God
and that his Keen concern on seeing people being well guided Allah tells us in the
Quran
it's almost as if you are going to kill yourself in grief
because of how much you seek guidance for others the prophet sallallah alaihi wasallam he experienced
a deep visceral care
for The Human Condition he really wanted guidance and wants guidance for all
and that is the spirit of the servant Prophet
it's that Mercy I have mercy and compassion that governs every single day
it's a tender awareness of those around me
I want people to be in the best of
States
not just in their physical
well-being or in their emotional well-being but most critically in their spiritual theological
well-being and you have to ask yourself how often do I really care about the guidance
of
others
how often do I really care about people's love
for Allah
and the love of the messenger Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam is that a concern that I
have for myself spouse
is that a governing concern that I really have for my children that I'm really concerned
I really want
my sister my brother my father my mother my aunt my uncle my cousins
my friends my community members my neighbors my classmates do I have that
governing
concern
of someone who sent as Mercy to all of
creation am I disposed as a servant
who's driven by that Spirit
that's a question that you have to ask because often
if I don't have that disposition if I'm thinking about myself if I'm thinking about my
career
that my the governing ideas of my day
are my welfare my happiness my proverbial purpose in life if that's the governing idea of
my day-to-day
reality
then there is no mercy there is no compassion there is no love
there is no beauty that exudes
it just doesn't happen it becomes harsh
and hard and painful and
dark
but because of the prophet's concern because of the prophet's love
you see even
those
who were hurting and harming him the
most
experiencing that Mercy in a very unique way in a way that they didn't even know
to appreciate that they were not even aware of the famous incident where he went to
T
in the latter part of the mechan period of the
S
when he was seeking Refuge
amongst those in
and ultimately they rejected him
and they bloodied him and they bruised him and they beat him and he entered into
a garden right outside of T
and he was sitting down
and the angel came down to him
and said to him you just give me the
command
and I will make it that the two mountains that surround th
that they will
destroy
this entire area this entire Village of th
the prophet sallallahu alaih wasallam said no no for my hope
is
that perhaps I hope that who will be come from their loins
will be someone
who is a servant of Allah you can only consider that
in the space of a servant
Prophet
who imbus
and exudes profound mercy and
compassion and has a foresight
that does not just look at the simple
transactional qualities of this world you know the push and pull but rather he's thinking about
the
he's thinking about the afterlife he's thinking about people's salvation he's thinking about The Offspring who's
going to come forth what is going to be the impact
of such a decision why am I am I doing this for me I would never
do this for myself that's what the prophet wasam said he never became angry when you
read his sh he never be became angry for himself everything that really drove him and
motivated and defined his decisions was this
servanthood this mercy and compassion so he was thoughtful he was thoughtful about the outcome I
want to see Believers no no no no it's okay I got blood Eed and bruised
I got hurt
but I'm okay I can survive this as long as Allah's not bothered with me then
I then I have no problems I don't want to see those people destroyed the prophet
was not a man of Destruction he was not a man of arrogance and ego and
vengefulness he wasn't self-centered and self-absorbed he didn't behave
you know like he was Upon A fom
no he had behaved and embodied this humble beautiful servant
spirit
that exuded endless amounts of mercy and
compassion for